so for a filmmaker that does have that
mindset that Oh a name is taking away
from quote our backers that'll back our
little zombie short do you think they
have the right mindset to make it in the
film business as brutal and as difficult
as it is do you think that's setting
them up with the right mindset look I
understand why they feel that way but
while they reason they feel that way or
ill conceived it's just not true and
they they just got to work hard to make
sure that their stuff is tight so when
people do look at their links that don't
wanna back then is it a cutthroat game
to get to your level do you think people
realize how hard that is oh I think
people realize I mean that's one of the
reasons why I mean some young filmmakers
have had those feelings towards your
vampire Mars Zach Braff myself because
it is a tug business but here's the
thing we were not some pirates showing
up to rape and pillar I've been always
been more than generous with my time and
money young filmmakers and that will
continue always and if I've told this to
Yancy and Perry who are the co-founders
of kick-started that if we make any
profits I will separate downman so that
the dividends could go to young
filmmakers on Kickstarter
you